so what are the best ways to earn money
from your YouTube channel this year what
are some of the opportunities in
affiliate marketing outside of just
Amazon they also have to be of some
benefit to my viewer so I always make
sure that the company can give me a
coupon code what are some of the unique
and out of the box ways to earn money
all of those topics are the subject
matter today in part two of my
conversation with Mary's Nest this all
goes back to the viewer you're always
doing everything with their best
interest just in mind it's when you put
them first is how you wind up making a
nice income to help support you and your
family now if you didn't listen to part
one it was all about starting about
getting your gear right your laptop your
editing camera as well as your mindset
and I highly recommend that Mary's story
is super inspiring and now in part two
she's going to be sharing some insights
of how she has built a simpl to sustain
YouTube business that supports her
family and breaking down how she is
earning money and from some of the
different income streams and of course
this is unique to Mary's Channel we
always recommend you got to figure out
the ideal and perfect business model for
your Niche your topic I'm convinced that
you're going to get nuggets and insights
that apply to everybody listening to
this episode of the think media podcast
so buckle your seat belt and let's dive
into part two of my conversation with
Mary's nest what are the list of the
ways now that creating YouTube content
actually earns your family money yes I
well I have the ads on my YouTube videos
and that uh produces income I also have
h a very active website that was such a
good thing you know I didn't see the
importance of that in the beginning and
my husband uh would say you know pay
attention to the website pay you know
you grow just like you're going to grow
YouTube you can embed your videos there
and you can have a nice blog post
that'll complement your YouTube video
and initially I I was so overwhelmed you
know with the videos in the very
beginning but then I really started
listening to him and I said oh I'm going
to really pay attention to the website
and that has been a very nice source of
income uh because I'm eligible uh for
Medi Vine which is a that puts ads on
your uh website and I really like
working with them because you can sort
of pick and choose you can tell them
what type of ads you want what type of
ads you don't want and they will work
with you to make the experience again
because it's always about the viewer and
maybe with a website you know it's about
the reader and I it's always in my mind
I want to make the best experience for
them possible and so you can work with
me media Vine to you know I don't
inundate with like a lot of ads but
enough ads to help bring in income so
that I can offset the cost of using WP
engine to make the experience for my
readers very nice and then also to help
offset the cost of I have a very large
email list and it's a verified email
list and I started collecting that bag
in the beginning which I learned you
know through video ranking
Academy and now and that was a delight
my publisher didn't even ask me about
that in advance and when my editor was
here I said oh by the way I have this
really nice email list and it's uh
they're all verified and I have like a
40% open rate he's like
really that's
great and so that but the media Vine and
then the AdSense on YouTube and then I
also I don't do any brand deals I just
have not felt comfortable about them yet
if going forward I decide it would have
to be only products that I've really
used for a long time and I would need a
lot of flexibility from the brand to
present it the way I wanted to present
it uh because I don't want to be heavily
controlled because my viewers expect me
to be me and so I've I I've gotten a lot
of offers for brand deals so if that's
something that your listeners are
interested in as as they build their
YouTube channel uh I have friends who
have small channels and they get offered
brand deals you know it's really just a
matter of what your Niche is uh but I do
have affiliate relationships of course I
have Amazon and that brings in income
but I have a lot of other affiliate
relationships and that are very
lucrative but I set rules for those and
this again goes back to the very
beginning and always focusing on my
viewer every affiliate relationship that
I established I only established with
companies whose products I bought on a
regular basis and used and felt very
strongly about that they would be
helpful to my viewers and I was only
willing to do an affiliate relationship
if the company was willing to give my
viewer a discount coupon code I don't do
you know Amazon it's a little different
I do have some affiliate relationships
that give me a discount code that the
people can use on Amazon but Amazon is
so many products you know that's kind of
its own situation but all of my other
affiliate relationships I that was my
rule I'm going to do them and they do
bring me an
income which is wonderful you know to
help my family but they also have to be
of some benefit to my viewer and so I
always make sure that the company can
give me a coupon code if they can't then
I I don't have an affiliate relationship
with them and what are some examples
of the lucrative just to think outside
of the box and and many listeners to
this are not going to have a cooking
channel per se but it it's inspiring to
hear because sometimes we do think
Amazon's the only show in town oh not at
all yeah so what is just kind of some
different types of products or brands
that could expand our thinking that
you've found to be powerful affiliate
programs well this is very interesting
yes you know having a cooking channel I
do have you know affiliate relationships
with companies that uh you know offer
food type products or baking type
products or culturing type products you
know I have I have all of that uh but a
uh Seed Company reached out to me now
I'm not you know it's it's not a direct
relationship however I do have a kitchen
garden and I do harvest food and I do
home Canon and this Seed Company it's
survival garden seeds and they are
terrific and they I learned about their
seeds because they have a very long
shelf life and when I talk about
stocking our prepper
pantries uh which really you know was a
a very hot topic during 2020 and is
continued on and I said this is great
this is something that I use I their SE
their seeds amazing you can store them
for eight years and they still Sprout
you know I I was laughing because I
planted their their um basil seeds and
every single one sprouted and I'm like
oh my gosh I've got to get more potting
soil and flower pots where am I going to
put all this basil so it wasn't like
direct with food but yet it had some
connection I'm not sure if that's
exactly what you mean like looking for
brands that may want to have affiliate
relationships with you that are not
directly related to what you're doing uh
every day on a daily basis but that
really resonated with my viewers they
were so happy when I shared with them
about that particular seed company and
the seed company was giving a discount
and so a lot of people were uh stocking
up on those for their pantries as as
well as gifts and so it really was a
win-win situation yeah I think with that
uh is kind of an Insight that we can
apply is you know we start before we're
ready and we can start before the entire
path is clear and we also at once we
start again we start to attract
opportunities because I would imagine
mid Journey some point you found this
seed company or they found
you and I on your website I've seen
things like mock milk or something like
that oh oh oh mock Mill that's a a Grain
Mill okay Grain Mill yeah us Wellness
Meats oh yes oh oh you wanted the names
of the companies yes mock Mill is a
Grain Mill and uh I keep I store whole
grain and I and I grain I grind their
mil I I grind the grain using their Mill
and that I bought that mock Mill myself
you know and I just so fell in love with
it and it's such a terrific uh Grain
Mill that I contacted them and I said oh
I have a YouTube channel and can you
give my viewers a dis a discount coupon
code and they was said sure and I was so
happy uh because so many of my viewers
were looking for a Grain Mill and one
that and recommended from someone that
they could trust and they could really
trust me because I had purchased that
myself and I loved it and then I was
able to offer the coupon code and I they
it was so cute because for a while
mockmill would show uh the like their
top sellers of Mo of of their grain
mills and I was always at the top and it
would make me very happy that so many of
my viewers were so thrilled to be able
to find something that would work well
and what I like about mckill is it's
very affordable yet it's a stone
grinding Grain Mill which that has some
significance to people who grind grain
and they were able to get a discount so
that just made me so happy but yes us
Wellness Meats uh and what's nice is
when you uh uh I have Mason tops you
know the fermentation people uh plan to
eat which is a meal planner that I like
very much because it's based on you just
dragging and dropping your own your own
recipes or ones that you find online
into a meal planner so you're not pigeon
told into making things that other
people are telling you to make I don't
like meal planners like that and uh
breadtopia with all of their you know
bread baking equipment bread smart you
know all these different people uh but
it's uh one thing that I want to share
about affiliate relationships is that
like for us Wellness meets for example
uh they give a very nice discount to my
viewers and they have programs where
they will highlight people who are using
their products and who have a YouTube
channel and so they had a month where I
mean I think it's cute I think I'm not a
chef I'm a home cook but I think they
use the terminology like chef of the
month and they had me one month and they
interviewed me and shared my recipes and
that helped my YouTube channel you know
because they link to my YouTube channel
and how to make bone broth and and so
how to roast bone marrow you know these
sort of unusual things but things that
they sell and when they come across uh
people whatever Niche you're in and with
whomever you develop affiliate
relationships with uh if you're using
their
products and highlighting them and
they're willing to give your viewers a
discount you're helping them so much and
at the same time you're being able to
create an income for
yourself and you get to the point where
you develop such a nice relationship
with your Affiliates I love all my I
love the people you know I interact with
them all the time I feel I just was
emailing one of my Affiliates this
morning and I I was saying boy you made
me feel like you're family uh these
people I have such warm relationships
with them so yes you and you can have
multiple I think it's very important
always have multiple streams of income
have your YouTube income have your
website income have your affiliate uh
relationship income have your I consider
Amazon kind of in its separate category
but have your Amazon uh shop and be
straightforward with it put the things
you put in your shop and the things you
link to for your viewers and the things
that you talk about in your videos
should be things you use and things you
you think highly of that I really think
helps generate sales on Amazon as
opposed to just filling with it don't
feel you have to just fill it with a lot
of stuff fill it with things you use and
things you share in your videos that you
like and that you think well of all of
this again this all goes back to the
viewer or in the case of the website the
reader that you're always doing
everything with their best interest in
mind and it's when you put them first is
how you wind up making a nice income to
help support you and your family we're
going to get back to the conversation
with Mary in just a second but today's
episode is brought to you by VAP
podcast.com if you're serious about
starting or growing a YouTube channel
this year and you want to learn our 7R
system that Mary used to now grow to
almost a million subscribers and build a
very lucrative business for her and her
family then check out vodcast
to find a special offer just for think
media podcast listeners on not just our
signature course video riken Academy but
some other cool bonuses that we're
including right now as well so if that's
of interest to you you can click a link
in the show notes or just go to V
podcast.com and now let's get back into
the episode I think if you if you just
focus initially on oh is this going to
make me money that's not smart that is
not that is such a mistake think of
what's going to benefit my viewer
and when they trust you and they're
things you use and then they buy them oh
my gosh the emails I get from my viewers
how happy they are with their Grain Mill
from mock Mill so th and so many people
wanted to learn how to make bread and
how to grind grain and store grain
instead of storing flour because grain
lasts longer all these things you know
they it just it it snowballs and over
time you develop such strong
relationships with your affili iot that
uh and it's cute because they're like
now they're saying oh you know will you
do brand deals with us you know will you
do this and and so down the road yes
I'll think about that uh because I've
developed a nice relationship where I
can really talk with these people this
is not just some big company who's
saying okay you have to do it like this
that's not me that's not my viewers yeah
so you again you have to be true to
yourself but you you can definitely
through all of these things and then
finally the fourth option at least for
me is I formed a membership group on uh
YouTube now I know some people you have
mixed emotions because YouTube does take
a big chunk of it but it is kind of nice
YouTube handles everything and you don't
have to deal with credit cards and all
of that uh and my my membership group
has been wonderful I I go live in my
membership group I do deep Dives in my
membership group and then that's another
stream of income
so I I think always focusing not just on
the ads on YouTube that's a great place
to get started and and Amazon is a great
place to get started but then just keep
branching out just keep looking for good
quality affiliate relationships think
about membership groups I know some
people do things outside of YouTube but
uh I'm very much a YouTube
girl so that's why I have my membership
you know on YouTube as opposed to other
sources like patreon and what whatnot I
uh YouTube has been very good to me and
and uh they've really helped me a lot
and uh taking your course you know has
allowed me to really be have a I think
if you if you're goal on YouTube is to
eventually have a silver play button or
eventually to have a gold BL play button
you got to have a little laser beam you
know don't spread yourself too thin
especially if your team is just yourself
or or you and a friend or a family
member don't spread yourself too thin if
if that's your goal stick with it you
know I don't I do have Facebook I do
have Instagram I do have Twitter but I
think the place to really grow and along
you know with the video ranking Academy
class you can do it on YouTube and and
you can make a a a very a nice income to
support you and your family
and yes there there are times it's
cyclical you know there is a little up
and down but if you're in it for the
long haul you're going to be fine Mary
this conversation has been just like
bone your bone broth is rich in
nutrients and flavor it's been rich in
wisdom and insights that can benefit all
of us as content preneurs entrepreneurs
and content creators um we're gonna make
this two parts so I'm excited if if
someone's they'll be coming to the end
the second part on our think media
podcast just because you've been adding
value for over an hour now and so um
just want to acknowledge you and just
say I'm so grateful you're you're just
doing it right and your humility
humility that you've maintained on the
other side of success um your servant
leadership uh commitment to continue to
put your Community First and to have
true love for your community you know uh
at think media we actually call it our
dress code which is a verse from the
book of Colossians where it says I think
it says brothers and sister sisters
clothe yourself in love and compassion
and humility and empathy and uh you just
embody that like your dress code it
doesn't really matter what we're wearing
what matters most is that inner
character and the light and love you
always say sweet friends as a subscriber
I see your community Tab and your
Instagram post it's always sweet friends
and having talked with you I could feel
the energy and I know everyone is
falling in love with you by the end of
time to say that just you you you it's
just so think it's so real and and then
the patience I think also one of the of
course big challenges between everybody
listening to this and YouTube success is
not just learning the skills and not
just figuring out the Frameworks but the
grit it takes to be thinking this isn't
just going to be a five minute thing
this is g to take five years but also on
the other side of patience and
perseverance you're just getting started
I mean it's wild to think like like your
book is just coming out like you're just
showing up on some people's radar right
now you're a little over 900,000
subscribers right you're going to be at
a million subscribers there's people who
are just discovering you right they
don't know you yet and they didn't know
that they wanted to start making
sourdough bread and getting healthy and
and uh getting better probiotics in
their life and all this kind of stuff
from fermented content uh so anyways I
just really acknowledge you and I'm so
grateful you've been a part of our
community you're an inspiration to the
whole VRA
and of course your community so um of
course linked up in the show notes is
all of your links but just shout out
anything you want to promote or where
can people follow you and connect with
you well pretty much everybody can
follow me on YouTube and other social
media is at Mary's Nest it's
everything's pretty much named the same
and uh of course my my website I have a
link to my cookbook the modern pioneer
cookbook it's also available on Amazon
and pretty much at all the the book
sellers uh Barnes & Nobles Walmart
Target it it's really quite something to
even see that but uh yeah I have a link
uh on my website uh to where people can
order my cookbook and no matter where
you are in the world you can order it
they do have international uh random
house has the international links also
so that in itself I'm telling you Sean
it blows my
mind no it's it's and you done the work
and you have uh committed to the process
and I want to encourage listeners
definitely pick up a copy of Mary's book
eating more natural food in a world full
of processed foods and eating food that
is going to give you energy and Health
and Longevity um is actually one of the
foundational game changers to sustaining
YouTube success as well just getting
that right so so many of us can benefit
from that and I can't even wait to uh
crack it open and for Sonia and I to
test out some of the recipes we'll
discover inside your book so Mary's nest
thank you so much for being a part of
the think media podcast oh Sean thank
you so much I I've said this you many
times I but it's true I really I I feel
very much a part of your family and as
well as the V family and I can't thank
you enough for all that you've done for
me and I I look forward to many years of
success thanks to you and I know that
all of your listeners and viewers love
you as much as I do whenever I talk to
Mary I always get inspired and I hope
you've gotten value out of this two-part
series that we've uploaded on the think
media podcast I want to encourage you
make sure you're subscribe because we
have some powerful episodes coming soon
wherever you consume the podcast whether
on YouTube or one of the audio platforms
and if this has been of value to you it
would mean the world to me if you rate
and review the podcast wherever you
listen to it on audio and if you're over
on YouTube make sure to smash the like
button and drop a comment with your aha
moment my name is Sean canel rhymes with
YouTube channel and I can't wait to
connect with you in a future episode of
the think media podcast